depuis fort longtemps et en tout cas dès
les pédiatres biochimiste et hygiéniste
se sont penchés sur les problèmes de
protection infantile
c'est ainsi que l'oeuvre des hobbits aux
marins à favoriser la création
d'établissements hélio marin destiné au
traitement des enfants du premier âge
atteints de certaines déficiences
physiques
le centre héliomarin de saint-trojan
dans l'île d'oléron est l'un des plus
importants de france
bénéficiant d'un climat idéal les gelées
sont pratiquement inconnu l'hiver dans
l'île d'oléron au milieu d'une forêt de
pins et de mimosa ce centre prévu tout
d'abord pour les malades pulmonaires en
raison de l'aérosol marron contenant du
chlorure de sodium et des particules
isolés bénéficient d'une lumière
éclatante produisant un phénomène de
réverbération intense ce centre donc en
raison de la régression de la
tuberculose s'est transformé très
rapidement pour la protection infantile
au milieu d'un parc de 90 mille mètres
carrés en bordure de mer 250 jeunes
filles de 17 à 23 ans s'occupe toute
l'année de 300 enfants de la naissance à
3 ans dont l'état de santé dystrophie
séquelles lésions osseuses catabolisme
accéléré nécessite des soins attentifs
pour résoudre les problèmes de la
croissance somatiques et de la
diététique sous le contrôle de quatre
médecins spécialistes 4 jardinières
d'enfants 20 infirmières puéricultrices
ces 250 jeunes filles soigne les 300
enfants comme s'il s'agissait de leurs
enfants
d'ailleurs lorsqu'ils ont atteint l'âge
de parler il les appelle maman
le matin dès le réveil c'est la toilette
de ces petits bambins de quelques mois
le bain le changement de linge pour cela
une véritable usine fonctionne l'avant
chaque jour 400 à l'aise et dra 10 900
couches 4 sans culottes de son tablier
sans salopette lac à londres entre des
mains expertes peut repasser 600 couche
alors 175 bras et 300 à l'aise cependant
que le séchoir rotatif sèche 30 kg de
linge en 20 minutes
mais la journée se poursuit la toile est
terminée c'est le biberon et pour ceux
qui refusent toute nourriture le gavage
dans certains cas d'asthme prononcer le
passage sous la tente à oxygène pour
d'autres la perfusion sous la
surveillance des infirmières attentive
au moindre réaction est prête à
intervenir mais c'est l'heure de
l'auscultation et chaque bébé est
minutieusement examinés chaque matin par
le médecin chef ou ses collaborateurs en
compagnie des infirmières notamment
l'infirmière en chef pour les cas
particuliers
bien sûr tout cela ne se passe pas sans
cris mais après ses mauvais moments que
de distraction sans compter les
promenades
cependant que nombreux sont ceux qui
jouent font la sieste les jardinières
d'enfants spécialiste en test de
réactions interviennent il est
indispensable de connaître dès le
premier âge le comportement non
seulement corporels mais cérébrale la
caution intellectuelle
trois fois par semaine il faut se
soumettre au test qui peut permettre un
changement de traitement
je me suis dit est ce que le fait oui un
fini c'est trop mou qui le tient le
tabac tout seul comme un fou
il ne nie pas son cul mais le test n'est
pas la seule opérations quotidiennes des
jardinières
il y a encore pour certains enfants les
grands handicapés physiques
le passage à la salle de mécano thérapie
il faut réapprendre à marcher faire des
mouvements permettant le renforcement de
l'ossature après tous ces soins pénible
certes mais pris avec le sourire
ce sera pour les grands et les petits la
récréation dans l'une des salles de jeux
muriel l'artiste du centre une petite
normande peint le portrait de notre
cameraman avec talent
croyez moi c'est bien lui cependant dans
d'autres salles
gilles catherine ou nathalie sous la
surveillance d'une jardinière joue et
chante
michaud
toute peine mérite salaire et pour un
enfant quoi de mieux qu'un bon repas
même s'il s'agit d'un régime pour cela
monsieur bourguignon chef de cuisine
prépare chaque jour vous fait préparé
par ces aides
plus de 100 régimes différents allant du
1er âge à trois ans de la purée légère à
la purée consistante des carottes cuites
avec la peau pour les vitamines au
délicieux potages et pour terminer après
les viandes hachées une très bonne pâte
ici depuis près de 50 ans monsieur
bourguignon et certains de ces aides
prépare ainsi les petites rations qui
doivent aide et l'action conjuguée de
l'air marin et des traitements médicaux
commencer la pathologie chirurgicale du
nourrisson et du jeune enfant par
l'appendicite pourvoir l'appendicite
nous allons avant de revoir rapidement
l'anatomie non seulement de l'appendice
mais justice de manière à bien
le situer l'appendice non seulement par
rapport au reste du digestif mais
également sa projection sur la paroi
abdominale de manière à bien vous
expliquer pourquoi me cherche on tait
les signes d'appendicite ici plutôt
qu'ailleurs la direction soucieuse de la
promotion sociale a ouvert un cours
spécial pour les meilleurs soignante
pour leur permettant d'accéder à la
situation supérieure celle d'infirmières
pour le médecin chef et tous ses
collaborateurs une seule question compte
en dehors des soins médicaux la propreté
l'hygiène est absolument de rigueur et
avant d'entrer au centre l'enfant confié
par la sécurité sociale à 100% passe
dans une salle de test où toute maladie
contagieuse détecter interdirait un
refus d'admission
la journée se termine dans ce centre
extrêmement moderne et adapté à la vie
actuelle par la promenade de tous ces
petits à travers les allées de mimosa ou
de sapin situer en un lieu excessivement
favorable le centre héliomarin de
saint-trojan est une réalisation et qui
mérite d'être placés parmi les modèles
du genre